so in my opinion we have some really bad
news for the Mandalorian so when John
fraver was asked after about season four
being confirmed they said are you
getting close to an endpoint now do you
have an end in their mind and this is
what he said no I don't I think the
beauty of this is that we're in a middle
chapter of a much larger story and
through we'll have resolution over time
with his characters I think that how
these characters fit into the larger
scope and scale but it's not like
there's a finale that we're built into
that I have in mind I'd love for these
stories to go on and on and so these
characters potentially could be with us
for a while and I really loved telling
stories in their voice and I love the
way their wrenches unfold and I'm
looking forward to doing much more so in
my opinion this really really worries me
because the main Lawrence the most
successful show is obviously they want
to keep making it so I feel like it's
just going to keep dragging on you if
they have no end goal in sight for like
all great TV shows work towards a big
big end goal like a big conclusion and I
was kind of hoping a man Lauren would do
the same thing where they'll all work
towards a big event including all of
another spin-off shows like book of
bourbon Fred astoker I had a feeling
they're all going to work towards one
massive event ending often demand law
and potentially were thrown coming into
the pitcher and them having like a big
battle or something like that you know I
mean that's just a random idea about
just some big event there that will work
towards and now a human they have no
insight and going and worries me that
they're just gonna keep dragging on and
when the story starts getting bad or
when people start getting sick of it
they'll just like interwine her into the
sequel Trilogy like end it there just
somehow Bridge the gaps between man Ward
and the sequels and I'm not a fan of
that but let me know what you guys think
in the comment section below I'll be
very curious to know your thoughts about
this but anyway that's about it for this
video If you haven't subscribed please
consider doing so thanks guys